when you live by polls Oliver does a
majority of Americans want insert his
policy here with no way to pay for it
guess what you die by the polls and
right now Donald Trump is doing well in
the polls and we've seen that Bernie
folds like a cheap suit if someone boos
him because that's where all of his
self-worth is tied up I do think that
Donald Trump is going to win 2020
I feel that I can declaratively state
that at this point but let me tell you
kind of wine I do want to know what you
think out there I'm definitely more
confident than at this point last year I
wouldn't say a hundred percent because I
don't want to be embarrassed but you
guys apparently have a problem with it
Thank You hall but I am more confident
because things have changed I used to
say that Bernie would be the hardest
candidate for Donald Trump to beat
I thought Elizabeth Warren will be the
easiest I still think that remains true
but I think that Bernie Sanders is
actually far easier to beat and he would
have been this time last year which
we'll get to in a second but really I
want to be very clear here don't get
complacent folks because now you have
some people that they're saying for
example all these people in this studio
saying a hundred percent they're lying
they're just not honest people my point
is don't take because bill doesn't get
to vote three million times it's still
only one vote so you need to go out and
vote don't even deal with this but thus
far here's the first point as to why I
think Donald Trump will be president in
2020 and you've heard me be critical of
him when I think it's necessary I'm not
a cheerleader I've talked about when I
think he he runs the risk of losing thus
far the Democrats the debates it's just
been an absolute mess exact about
minimum wage I'm heavy wage the question
is building the millions of juda Liam
Park affordable housing raising taxes
she's wearing a look that looks like a
pre-fight press conference they've done
something remarkable Democrats it's a
miracle
they've made President Trump seem sane
and like the only adult in the room man
this is like we need some reason here
can someone bring in president Trump
till the only front-runner we have right
now is Bernie okay
let's talk about this kind of this
schism he cause he's caused this massive
rift in the Democratic Party okay so you
have a step you have these other
Democrats or they call them now
establishment Democrats as they used to
be known all non Bernie Democrats and
then you have Talking Heads who are
basically saying that Bernie Sanders
who's the front runner is a stooge a
Nazi he's a he's a tool for Putin but
basically pretty similar to everything
that they threw at Donald Trump the
happiest person right now it's about 115
Moscow time this thing is going very
well for Vladimir Putin I promise you
he's probably staying up watching us
right now it's helping him have plans to
help them run their primary when I was
at Bernie Sanders wins I'm pretty sure
he has a lot to say about billionaires
no one but Bernie Stephanie come on he's
an anarchist
would love to burn down the United
States I'm reading last night about the
fall of France in the summer of 1940 and
the general renault calls up Churchill
and says it's over the day went Bernie's
sitters to take over the Democratic
Party in perpetuity well I mean he could
he said over he sets the direction for
the future the party
maybe they'd rather wait four years and
put it in the Democrat that they like
Chris Matthews always seemed surprised
that he has that job it's a Christmas
that's the camera life so you have
Bernie on the flip side and all of his
supporters right and I understand the
pushback but this is why it's only going
to get worse I think for the Democrats
at least for the time being until they
narrow this down or they accuse all non
Bernie supporters of being establishment
and centrist or just flat-out evil
billionaire elitist that's their attack
as you may have noticed lately
the establishments getting a little bit
nervous I wanted to go back to what you
said about our Left Party we don't have
a Left Party in the United States
Democratic Party is not a Left Party she
says well literally sitting to the left
of that gentleman he burned his mouth on
a piece a lot of folks were concerned
about his rise and his surge especially
among young voters that this may be
causing some trouble for the
establishment does that concern you at
all well we need to cause trouble for
the establishment because the
establishment is who we're fighting
against it has come up from a candidate
who almost all de stablishment has
pinned their main hopes on and he's
talking about bribing politicians in a
positive way yeah he's saying never lose
racks talking to Goldman Sachs he didn't
have to repeat it they all already knew
remember Goldman Sachs well you do with
politicians as you bribed them because
it wouldn't want to talk to people at
Goldman Sachs no that would be
absolutely absurd establishment is just
the word of a threat here's the crazy
thing compared to Donald Trump because
and others have been talked about with
Donald Trump he's anti-establishment
but there's there's something to it
right there's there's some teeth to it
because if your aunt is
publish Minh as a conservative as an
outsider as a Republican you're actually
trying to some degree tear down the
system you're actually trying to some
degree to shrink the role of the
establishment in DC when Bernie
complains about the establishment it's
because he yearns to be that he wants to
have or Bloomberg when they talk about
the establishment they want to determine
what sodas you can drink whenever
someone says pro-choice I don't use that
term they're pro-abortion I'm pro-life
their proportion they're not pro-choice
when it comes to what car you can drive
what kind of soda you can drink what you
can pay in taxes where you can send your
charitable donations or not pro-choice
and any other facet outside of ending
the life of another human being inside
your stomach right they're not
pro-choice at all it's remarkable to me
they're anti howdy how can you be
anti-establishment just like Rage
Against the Machine when they campaign
for Obama
yeah you raid against the Machine by
endorsing it except for this machine I
used to think Bernie would be tough why
let me take explain to you and this was
a lot if you go back and watch the
segment's I thought okay Hillary Clinton
lost a lot of states that surprised me
for example Michigan I think Bernie does
well in those states because of the
unions right it's it's it's easy to
appeal to unions as a socialist or more
a lot of the union's just believe that
Hillary Clinton was an elitist and the
same thing with Michael Bloomberg right
I don't think that Michael Bloomberg has
any chance of winning the Rust Belt I
think Bernie has a better choice or at
least I thought he would have had a
better choice to win the Rust Belt
against Donald Trump and that's kind of
what he needs to win this election
here's the thing though now we've
reached a different point he's a
socialist revolutionary right
self-described well the revolution means
a 180 change in direction it means
you've got to change everything because
nothing's working but ninety percent of
Americans don't want that right now
ninety percent of Americans are
satisfied with their own personal
finances things are getting better for
the average American a lot better the
tax cuts they reduced in cut the income
tax bill for by the way not just a super
wealthy the median income households by
nearly 60% record low unemployment also
layoffs also high job participation rate
we have increases in household income
wage growth record-breaking stock market
on top of that we have people are
finally take note of how good the
economy is according to a poll because
Mr Sanders is almost entirely determined
by polls if you look at his policies
usually well if you look at 80% support
90% of the of the they debts a lot of
people
it's like almost all we understand
Bernie that you had a bad high school
experience and now you want some friends
alright we get it just like the guy who
shows up to a party with an acoustic
guitar bus puff-puff pass your pizzas
that's my point okay but here's the
thing the Trump economy right now he
actually has the highest economic
approval rating of any president in the
last 20 years overall approval right now
that's gonna be 9% yeah his overall
approval rating and if he compares
disapproval way better than Barack Obama
at this point in his presidency so it's
really hard I don't know what the
argument is and this is why you see that
letter that was being circulated from
from Nancy Pelosi if you were saying I'm
a socialist revolutionary I need to
change this system that would make sense
after the economic collapse right right
know when you're going back to the stock
market crashed in 2008 okay absolutely
it doesn't really make sense that we're
gonna tear this whole system down and
start anew when it's better than it's
ever been
according to 90% of Americans I think
Bernie Sanders is far less appealing
right now and the numbers should startle
them and I think it's important to note
by the way this has been a boat
turnaround so you want to talk about the
radical change the radical that well
first off let's go back through history
the radical idea was this idea of a free
society of free enterprise we didn't
want Realty we didn't want what
effectively developed into what we now
know as European socialism I know that
didn't exist back in the day but we are
talking about an oppressive government
who had too much control of people's
lives this country was a great
experiment in that we said government
limited the role I've described this
before it's like a hockey referee right
you keep the pace of the game make sure
the players are safe otherwise you keep
your mouthpiece in period you keep your
mouthpiece your whistle I was like
what's the word my wienie whistle the
whistle the rake whistle and hockey you
keep it in your pocket in other words
you do not overly invade people's lives
you don't call fouls or you don't call
penalties that have nothing to do with
the action around the puck if someone's
not hurting anybody that's not the role
of the government right it's a very
libertarian stance that is the role of
the government then we had Barack Obama
and by the way not just Barack Obama you
could also toss george w bush in there
and you could toss Bill Clinton in there
they were all pretty big government
Republicans I have to acknowledge that I
think a lot of people do and then Donald
Trump campaign on reversing that course
and here's the thing
before Donald Trump I was worried that
you would never have any other
conservative and now we see generation Z
is going to be the most conservative
generation ever why we had a lot of
people baby boomers right if people look
at boomers now it has become ocher
boomer which is so disrespectful it's
like really really you're texting that
from the phone who would that it was
created by boomers you asked okay boomer
you mean like Steve Jobs and Bill Gates
you ungrateful little pissant
so well Bernie is actually older than a
Boomer that's why they're right I guess
people say to him okay greatest
generation of all time but not you
though
so I think it's important to note like
baby boomers were really really liberal
everyone's putting the Daisy right now
in the rifle they were flower power and
then what happened they experienced
Jimmy Carter and then they experienced
Ronald Reagan so they had contrast and
then they became more conservative when
they got older and I was always
concerned when I grew up I was saying
man we don't really have that in her
lifetime we have Bill Clinton and George
W Bush there's not really that strong of
a contrast and then we had Barack Obama
that was a continuation of that and yeah
he's definitely more charismatic so I
thought young people since they don't
have the contrast of conservatism versus
leftism they're not going to naturally
revert back to being conservative as
they get older like baby boomers did all
that's required for people to be more
conservative as they age is that they
witness it put up until Donald Trump no
one had witnessed it or anything even
close to it but here's the thing
when Bernie Sanders talks about being a
revolutionary no the revolutionary sort
of about-face the change was Donald
Trump going in and it's what they [ __ ]
about the slashing of regulations the
slashing of taxes for people across the
board this is very new for people who
might be in their early 20s entering the
workforce we're now even if they're
liberal they they have this as a
baseline and then what happens if
there's another Barack Obama or another
Bernie Sanders who admitted that anyone
making over 29,000 is going to see a
drastic increase in taxes go back to our
segment on that with universal health
care Medicare for all so if you have a
22 year old liberal today who thinks
that he likes Bernie Sanders but he's
getting X amount in his paycheck then
Bernie becomes president and it's X
minus 20 percent 10 percent guess what
you've made a conservative for life
right so I think it's important to
realize that the rock against bush NOFX
Rage Against the Machine they are again
they are the Machine Bernie Sanders is
offering nothing new and the good thing
here is that it's going to create more
conservatives in this generation than I
think we've ever seen and now since the
polls are
good for Bernie and they're good for
Donald Trump Bernie has decided to not
so much focus on the economy he is
determined to make sure that you know
he's going to get do everything in his
power at least you know promises to get
an F rating from the NRA I have today a
d-minus voting record from the NRA
thirty years ago I likely lost a race
for the one seat for Congress in Vermont
because thirty years ago I opposed I
supported a ban on assault weapons we
must be aggressive on gun safety not be
dictated to by the NRA and I am proud
and I have a d-minus voting record from
the NRA if elected president it will get
worse than that ladies and gentlemen
your f president by the way hit the
notification bell if you're subscribed
here on YouTube and hit all
notifications because subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot and do consider
joining mug club I know a lot of you
enjoy the Thursday show we have shows
behind the paywall every day similar to
this and podcasts which other comm slash
Mudd Club and of course there's there's
Mark Levin you have Dave Rubin you have
Allie Stuckey you every millennial you
have Glenn Beck you have all kinds of
people over there we try to give you
your dollars with and we're not funded
by a foreign caliphate huh
so you know but we'll take it al Jazeera
I know that you're out you're in the red
you're just hemorrhaging money that
Young Turks investment isn't quite
paying off you to had to step in with
their news initiative but yeah we can do
it we'll even wear the funny hats so
here's something other thing people are
forgetting why do I realize I don't
wanna say he's a good debater but Donald
Trump is a very effective debater yeah
and you have that you have some people
like this who were who are for example
in analogy would be boxers like I would
love that George Foreman on the show I
think he would be one of the best guests
ever George Foreman was criticized for
not being a great boxer that may or may
not be true he was a very effective
boxer a lot of you said he would do is
he would use this sort of cross guard he
would go in and use a technique that
kept himself safe that didn't really
look pretty but he knocked everybody out
before ollie
pretty much well and then he won the
heavyweight championship at 42 so do not
underestimate how effective Donald Trump
can be on the debate stage
whoever it
in watching these debates I think he'll
eat their lunch so for comparison I want
you to look at how Bernie Sanders
reacted to two boos from the crowd at
this week's to be what I said is what
Barack Obama said in terms of Cuba that
Cuba made progress on education yes I
think really he's almost like Chris
Matthews that's really understand yes
we'll you crazy old coot so that's him
reacting to boos now let's compare this
with a stacked audience exactly Donald
Trump in the same scenario this was
someone actually a Bernie fan I think he
tweeted this out to Twitter does Bernie
Sanders need to do this if the booing
doesn't stop and this is the clip let me
talk
[Laughter]
[Music]
his owners and special-interest so
well they just tell you we needed
tickets you can't get them you know who
has the tickets for the I'm talking
about to the television audience donors
special interest the people that are
putting up the money
the RNC told us we have all donors in
the audience and the reason they're not
loving me their money I'm gonna do the
right thing for the American public I
don't want their money I don't need
their money and I'm the only one up here
that can say that yeah yeah he knows the
real audience yeah in the room that's a
very people there yes he know the
audience of people watching at home that
well that couldn't have been more
embarrassing for Jeb Bush if Donald
Trump rested his scrotum and testicles
on his forehead national television and
this has changed politics I think a lot
of people just say Oh Donald Trump went
against the establishment no yeah it's
important obviously a lot of these
people have consultants a ground game
has talked about a lot but people talk
about a ground game it's not as
important as it used to be now the
ground game won Ted Cruz Iowa great I
think it won Bernie Iowa not mistaken
with Hillary Clinton I know Rick
Santorum won Iowa back in the day when
and then it end up being Mitt Romney so
that's important but guess what with the
internet now everything you say at any
point is the ground game because people
in Iowa will see that people in New
Hampshire will see that and Donald Trump
understood he didn't need to speak to
the moderators he didn't need to speak
to people in the audience he needed to
speak to people at home which is ironic
considering that Bernie fences himself
you know a man of the people and he was
so flustered by these donors there in
the audience booing him you shouldn't
care you shouldn't care about it it
should not be less relevant the people
at home are the ones who matter and this
is what was interesting two replies were
from people on Twitter the response is a
couple of saying holy crap no wonder he
got elected look at all these people
responding on Twitter so for a lot of
these folks this is another reason I
think that Donald Trump is going to win
this is the first time in three years
they've actually watched Trump in a
debate instead of a clip that CNN has
sliced and diced to make them look bad
right this is these disasters that are
democratic debates are forcing Americans
who are not necessarily pro Trump to go
alright okay I'm not getting any of this
let me see what Donald Trump has to say
is opposed to playing that game of
telephone with Don Lemon saying what
Donald Trump has to say and you see the
reaction there and oh my god
oh my god you know what not only is that
a good point this is gonna be really
hard to deal with and most importantly
it shows that President Donald Trump has
faced the exact same situations as you
see with Bernie Sanders and he's handled
them far better but it is remarkable
this is we can see a direct comparison
booze from a stacked crowd with Bernie
boos from a stacked crowd with trumpet
it's very rare that before the actual
debate of the two candidates once they
go through the primaries that you get to
see the exact same scenario for a
comparison for a contrast we have that
there and it begs the question why can
Trump just speak through the boos and
not care at the exact same issue where's
Bernie shrinks into his suit like Tom
Hanks at the end of baked so let's go
through the candidate role cook we have
to get the Edmund Guinness um
Warren let's say any of these people
choose I was a probably not going to be
the candidate Warren Trump wins why
because he just bullrushes her right
she's not gonna walk it back the closest
we have is from an apology from Trump is
with Carly Fiorina in all I said was you
got a good face she's good she's got a
good face right because he knew she was
gonna go after him yeah Warren he's not
gonna back away from Pocahontas no way
he's only going to get where she has no
feet but gig no spine no way he can
handle it it's going to look like a
father spanking a child and you know it
I hate to say it looks like it looked
but gig also every time they turned to
him I expect him to answer was but I
don't know I also don't think he's gay I
think is I think he's the only straight
man who's gay husband is a beard
it's not much chested club would char
she's kind of an unpredictable one here
I think she would actually probably the
hardest candidate for Trump to beat I
don't think it's like that she's a
nominee what we've done we'll try and do
a club with her just make stuff up
that's probably would do it's like she's
an unknown the Oppo they would hand him
off a research he'd go no I think I'm
gonna say that she's contaminating
drinking would what are you talking
about I'm winning Mike Bloomberg I think
Mike Bloomberg if he's the nominee some
people think he might I think he defeats
himself listen this guy
is Midwest poison especially if he picks
Hillary Clinton as a running mate if
people saw Hillary Clinton as an elitist
I don't know how they couldn't see that
with Mike Bloomberg and by the way he
didn't ban big gulps this is a lobby he
been drinks over 16 ounces yeah what a
dick right that's no good and as it
comes to Bernie okay this is this is
Bernie listen we have a socialist
revolutionary who wants to revolutionize
the way we were living in America which
is the best economy that we've had on
record safer no major Wars we're doing
better than ever I think that his whole
pitch is unappealing and he's also
basically a pinko commie who went on his
honeymoon to the USSR and now we know is
fearful of the crowd when you're in town
when you live by polls Oliver does a
majority of Americans want insert his
policy here with no way to pay for it
guess what you die by the polls and
right now Donald Trump is doing well in
the polls and we've seen that Bernie
folds like a cheap suit if someone boos
him because that's where all of his
self-worth is tied up I don't think he's
going to be as popular as he thinks he's
going to be I think it's a walk-off for
Donald Trump barring something
completely unforeseen now your screens
not frozen this is one of those this is
one of those moving pictures takis see
that okay there's a video playing
somewhere in a box subscribe hit the
notification bell if you are subscribed
because subscriptions don't mean a whole
lot but we really do love having you on
this channel and I hope you enjoyed this
Bernie video because I know he didn't
and I can you know I can still live with
myself it didn't freeze it's still me
okay click one of the things